As promised, let's touch upon a few optimization view modes that we can look at here. So our
first one is going to be lighting complexity. And what is lighting complexity and how do
we use it? So we can actually get to the view modes as well I should say, by from the editor,
you can go to show on the top of the editor window, and you'll be able to see these different
view modes. So one of the properties will be optimization view modes. And then you can
go and find lighting complexity. Now in more recent versions of Unreal Engine, so I think
it's Unreal Engine 5.1 onwards, you can actually just click show and you can actually type in the
box. If you typed in lighting complexity, it would find the lighting complexity option. So
that's useful to keep in mind. But lighting complexity shows how many non static lights
are affecting your geometry. So the more non static lights you have affecting a surface,
the more expensive it'll be. So red means the area will have performance issues when it's run,
so you can see it gets a little bit expensive on the right hand side here. And ideally,
on this left hand side, you want these darker blues to brighter greens for the lighting
complexity. As you move lights around increase or decrease the radius, you can see the cost
that the lights have and that will change the complexity. So on the shading complexity,
if lighting complexity showed how many non static lights are affecting the geometry,
the more this on the shader complexity side, the shader complexity is showing how many
shader instructions it has to run to render each pixel. So green means that it only took a few,
whilst white can mean 1000 plus render passes. So ideally, you want to see all of this green
information, green or dark green is more ideal. And you can see that when we're looking at
transparency, whether it be on the headlights or the car windshield, it'll get worse, the more
translucent objects we have to look at. So we want to reduce the material complexity and make sure
we're not wasting too much transparent space. And we can also take on practices that we learned in
the previous mesh optimization series that can reduce some transparency as well. Lastly,
we'll talk about quad overdraw. And quad overdraw, if we think about GPUs work on a two by two quad
granularity, which means thin and small triangles, small and two by two, these can result in lots
more work to calculate than bigger pixels on the screen or bigger triangles on the screen. So you
can lessen the impact on this by making use of LRDs that get rid of smaller triangles that can't
be seen from a distance. But also we want to make sure we have as much blue sharp as possible. So
the more green into the pinks and purples, it gets super expensive. So this is a relatively
okay image. But if you could pull your camera back from this car, you'd want to make sure you
had LRDs in place to reduce some of the complexity of this mesh here.